l'avenir des salariés de la clinique
sainte-marie est toujours en suspens le
30 avril dernier c'était la quatrième
fois qu'ils étaient confrontés aux
représentants du groupe kapa devant le
juge du tribunal de commerce
toujours pas de proposition de
l'employeur permettant d'orienter la
clinique vers un plan de continuation
on a pas de dialogue avec la direction
on n'a pas le dialogue on n'a pas
jusqu'à maintenant le monsieur k gini
monsieur d'agapè ne nous a mis des rp
autour d'une table pour discuter vous
nous dire ce qu'ils ont qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont un projet pas de projet médical rien
du tout donc on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas c'est le flou total
le noeud est loin de se défaire les
expertises sur l'avancée des travaux
réclamés par les salariés il y a
quelques mois a été rendu lors de la
dernière audience
elle n'est pas convaincante disent les
représentants syndicaux de la cdmt il
exige donc un complément d'expertisé sur
la valeur du matériel
l'approximation honnête mais n'a pas
d'avenir et j'avais bois des libres 2
mais consent galice à faire 4e foire aux
cerises au tribunal il n'y a jamais eu
de plan de continuation
parce que moi je dis quant à vous vous
privez faire leur coordination
il ya un staff y a dix médecins qu'elle
se rende oil et honnêtement je n'ai
jamais tenus au comédien prises dans le
bloc dit aux gars ils étaient convoqués
borny monsieur nagapen nicole kadjou
pour savoir dans quelle direction va
l'aider après coordination de quel
projet pour vale moi je n'ai jamais
connu ça
sur la question des licenciements le
juge vient de rendre sa décision
il autorise l'administrateur judiciaire
de la clinique sainte-marie à licencier
20 9 salariés pour raisons économiques
une décision que l'ensemble des salariés
contestent ils ont déposé un recours
cette semaine au tribunal mixte de
commerce de repreneurs se sont fait
connaître
doc tg ciot qui n'a pas encore fourni
son plan de reprise et la clinique saint
paul de façon officielle dans son plan
cette dernière propose ou moins de
licenciements
la prochaine audience est prévue ce 26
juin